[Music]
thank you don't give me any more
attention cuz it'll all go to my head
okay let's hold these numbers up and
we're gonna start with 168 and then I'll
go - come on ask your wedding I'm ready
just gotta get him a microphone
okay 68 over here guys you have no money
Marko call me Marco that's fine I don't
know who that is
to the right of the left where am I
looking
I'm sorry sir I just found out about
this last week there is has always been
available to all everybody that get that
does a negotiation on a film an
inclusion writer which means that you
can ask for and or demand at least 50%
diversity in not only the casting but
also the crew and so the fact that we
that I just learned that after 35 years
of being in the film business it's not
we're not going back so the whole idea
of women trending no no trending
african-americans trending no no
trending it changes now and I think the
inclusion writer will have something to
do with that we're going to great power
power and rules 28 and then 261 right
French oh oh my god it's like we're like
we're bidding on art hey
it's shut up your paddle where are you
my paddle is right oh yeah yes sir
Francis Steve Futterman from CBS News
congratulations thank you I want to ask
you about a bit of a follow-up to that
question the tone of the evening
obviously it's about awards but there
was certainly throughout the evening the
idea that this was a different Oscars
than in the past because of what has
happened since not since October no it
actually was it happened way before that
I think that what happened last year you
know with moonlight winning the Best
Picture that's when it changed and and
it had to be acknowledged that had to be
acknowledged and it was acknowledged in
the best possible way not just by you
know fixing the mistake but actually
recognizing that that won best picture
of moonlight won best picture of 2017
I'm sorry go ahead your question
well yeah you know it was really
interesting because like I said feeling
like I was Chloe Kim doing back to back
10 80s in the halfpipe I was I was a I
don't do everything as you know I don't
show up all the time I only show up when
I can and when I want to but I was there
at the Golden Globes and it and it's
almost like there was an arc that
started there it doesn't end here but I
think publicly as a commercial because
that's what we are this is not a this is
not this is not a novel this is a TV
show after all but but I think that the
metrans that we're getting to send to
the public is that we're going to be one
of the small industries that try to make
a difference and I think 21 million
dollars in the Legal Defense Fund is a
great way to start and the Commission
that that's being headed by Anita Hill
that's really smart see we didn't just
we didn't just put out commercials about
it we actually started a conversation
that will change something yeah we're
coming here to say yeah time your heart
congratulations anti-american urban
radio networks in online okay three
billboards has started a movement if you
seen the Billboard oh are you kidding
off the screen and onto the street
really about it I want to hear what your
comment is about well you know recently
my husband and I were in London at the
Baptist and we went to the Tate Modern
and we saw an exhibition about the
Russian revolutionary Russian Revolution
and the propaganda that was used now
that revolution did not go so well so we
don't want to think too much about that
but the red and black is a really really
good choice and Martin McDonagh knew
that he was involved in the choice with
the with the set design of the film to
use that kind of iconography and I think
the idea that activists are taking that
kind of statement and putting it out
there billboards still work they still
work so I think that it's really
exciting ya know it started actually
with the Grenville tower fires
investigation then it will then it then
it leapfrog to them
I am a gun control situation it was
outside the UN about the Syrian
situation you know it's the kind of
that's the kind of power that an image
can have and that's what we're making
we're making powerful images we are
gonna wrap it up with 194 of France's
congratulations thank you actually three
billboards just released in China three
days ago yes and it's a very American
movie what would you like to say to
Chinese audience well I'd like I'd like
to know are they going to see it are
people going to see it has over 1
million 1 million dollars okay we need
to get a little bit more people to
cinemas I don't know how to do that but
maybe you can help I don't know what
would you like me to say what would you
like to say I think that it is not
America does not represent America but
it represents a really good conversation
about compassion and and inclusion how
about that good thank you good night
thank you congratulations